first of all i saw a comment yesterday
saying my favorite part of the podcast
is when kai comments
well well actually all right we are
officially live
episode 33 we have daniel the martino
booth back here with us
and adam yes and we have kai for another
couple hours before he takes a
nice little how many hour flight what is
it from here to norway
18 hours from here to go to norway which
is going to be excellent
norway is going to raise interest rates
for the first time they're going to be
the pioneer central post covet central
bank to raise interest rates so
enjoy yourself kai you're going to the
land of the frugally fiscally frugal go
are they the only ones that are raising
interest rates they're they um
the news hit the wires this morning the
the norja's bank is expected to be the
first
i love how danielle goes right to the
interest rate right to fed not enjoy
norway merry christmas
by the way so so let me ask you how are
you feeling we haven't spoken for a
while just kind of give me an update on
how you're feeling from last time to
this time economy
biden election everything that's going
on where are you at with all that stuff
i mean so
i'm happy that we've got past a certain
few milestones if you will but right now
it's a foot race
i'm watching the foot race i'm watching
the foot race between the vaccine
dissemination
and how that trickles down into an
economic rebound
and the immediate damage that the
economy
is is withstanding right now so it is it
really everything's going to key off of
i think
how christmas gatherings go and i mean
it really is
that what do you mean by that christmas
gatherings like meaning if there's
if there's another super spreader
thanksgiving super better event i mean
we had 3 800 deaths in the united states
yesterday
we've never seen a number like that
there the census bureau reported today
that there are five million americans
who are not working because they're sick
with covid
i mean these are strange statistics that
are coming out but if
if we pile onto this thanksgiving super
spreader another one at christmas
we could theoretically go back into
recession in the first quarter well i
have a prediction yeah
i think we everyone is going to spend
christmas together i don't think
anyone's
and then i think doubling down yeah
everybody is i don't think everyone's
still going to do christmas together yes
are you are you doing your traditional
christmas deal well we are
we it is up in the air whether or not we
bring my mom into dallas okay so that's
the only thing you were changing
super seniors what are you changing with
christmas are you going and
seeing mom and his family going to go
yes so you're not changing it i'm doing
hanukkah christmas kwanzaa i'm doing it
all and then we're doing new readings
but i mean i'm not seeing my 85 year old
grandma like that's not would you
typically go see her
i would she would be around yeah that's
the thing okay so that's what's changing
keep the old and the sick away
yeah you know that's not very nice to
say that way but
no no like keep them safe keep them away
put them all the way they're not
necessarily sick
just keep all the way old yeah that are
more susceptible maybe
the sicker yeah you know health issues
you know what i mean we may compromise i
mean
nana's pretty good about it you know she
can like sit over in the corner of the
room with her mask on and
and and enjoy the festival you're going
to put nancy so you may you're thinking
maybe
maybe she's got her own place to stay in
the house corner can sequester
well you're putting grandma on the couch
text text nobody puts grandma on the
corner we all know that come on
so you could put prank grandma what
about you you got some
here's what i was trying to do i i got a
14 bedroom house
in lake tahoe we all did and we were we
were going to bring
all our uh board uh field advisory board
together and we're going to spend the
yeah what do you call it that uh four
nights together
okay at late time christmas we were and
then
i get a uh article that comes up from
guardians saying the fact that lake
tahoe shut down
heavenly shut down the slopes shut down
everybody shut down
you can't have more than 10 people in
the place and i called the guy i'm like
listen this just came out
i saw this i said look we can't do it
don't even worry about it he refunds the
thing so
guy was a stand-up guy they ended up
doing the deal uh
and we now looked at other places to
where we want to go to whether we're
going to go to florida all this stuff
i called the guy and i told you this the
other day i called the guy and the guy
tells me the brokers tell me
focus if you're going to go get a place
focus on red states if you're going to
go anywhere because red states are going
to leave it open
blue states are going to lock down so he
says if you want to go to new york not a
good idea
you want to go to vermont not a good
idea you want to go to colorado stay
away from colorado you want to go to
this place
so typical aspen lake tahoe new york you
know vermont
these places that i said so what's left
he says you're looking at florida
florida florida florida florida and
honestly it's florida and florida
florida so we're most likely looking at
florida
and uh it's not going to be the 25 30
people that we would have done it's
probably only going to end up being 12
of us why not
alabama west virginia i looked at
alabama i looked at alabama we want to
let's go red
oh if we're going to go red state let's
go bama would have been amazing yeah
don't knock orange beach until you've
tried it i'm sorry that's the is that
the redneck riviera yes it is
yeehaw i know i can totally see you
going there by the way in the panhandle
i went to
florida state shout out to all my
florida state seminoles out there
and uh fsu but you know i know about the
panhandle but i'm a
south miami south florida kind of a guy
got it well but you know i mean look
in defense of in defense of blue states
which
okay i've never said those words um so
there's there's a first
mobility trends in states with
high positivity rates of covet
very red states have come cratering down
so a lot of it is the nana discussion
the grandmother discussion that we just
had a lot of states
if they follow their local news they're
not relying on
governments they're not relying on their
local officials to tell them how to
behave
they're they're choosing for which which
you know what a lot of
red governors have said you can make
your own decisions
exactly you can be as prudent as you
want to be what do you think about that
and we have seen
a lot of americans do exactly that yeah
and and make their own choices to not be
mobile
their economies get hurt just the same
yeah so
the the they're not necessarily the same
though you're saying florida gets hit
the same as california
no no no no no i'm saying when i'm
saying states like
like north dakota again oh okay
wisconsin i'm trying to think about the
red states that have been
really hit hard by covid where there are
no restrictions and yet
the economic growth has slowed
appreciably so right but i mean you can
i mean look
the blue states have taken this too far
i'm so sorry but i mean here in dallas
we get the same kind of
benefit of being able to eat outdoors
for a long
part of the year you don't shut down
outdoor eating in l.a county
that's just excuse it's in l.a in l.a
yeah we're just talking about it's crazy
it's just crazy la new york a bunch of
different places this week
i think it's safe well new york you you
can't i mean yeah there's no snow on the
ground you can't exactly eat outside
outdoor eating in new york this week for
sure
well i mean the blizzard talk about the
blizzard what the hell is 12 to 24
inches more than
all of last winter combined in the span
of a couple days okay but before we move
on to that because i want to see some
pictures of the snow
i used to live there the wall street
journal
uh showed that data that showed that
that restaurant indoor eating was
responsible for 1.4
of kova transmissions and indoor family
gatherings were responsible for 74
percent of covet transmission
so there's as long as those numbers 1.4
1.4
percent is restaurants which is
exhibitable to restaurants i mean it's
long enough
what was the other 74 74 family
gathering that's
crazy hold up so they're saying that
you're getting more covered from being
around your family than
being around the strangers they want you
to go out eat drink be married just
don't do it in the house
look in seoul in seoul south look they
never
closed the restaurants in seoul ever
since they just they just yeah
yes they emptied out half the tables you
know they
emptied out half the tables social media
social distance they put their masks on
and business didn't skip a beat i mean
that's how you kind of do it so
when you see cuomo and de blasio trying
to put the last nail in the coffin of
new york
it makes i mean you cannot close the 21
club
it's just it's sad there should be a law
against something like that and 148
employees that went with it
i'm going to ask pat a few questions uh
covid and business related
so let me let me let me set this up and
then i'd love to get your
response on this uh number one we've
seen you've done an episode about covid
mask you've done all that
you've also done another episode
recently where you interviewed business
owners right
so i think i saw that forty percent of
all code
covet deaths are in nursing homes
something with that effect we understand
that covet is real
for all my deniers out there it is real
but it's not as lethal as we initially
thought people are certainly getting
sick but
kind of like what danielle said when you
did your episode we've seen these
businesses these small businesses these
restaurants
daniel's saying one percent of coveted
cases are tracked to restaurants i'd
love to there's
restaurants
meaning bars is higher right and plus um
a
bar is the reason bars are so much more
transmission petri dishes it's because
you've got loud music on
you tend to have a younger crowd and
they're yelling over the music to talk
to each other
and they're they're closer together
because they're talking about things
people talk about in a bar
yeah that's a big difference in a
restaurant that's a lot different than
restaurants you know than tables that
are spaced out six feet apart blah blah
blah
much different environment what have you
seen uh you know speak to that to the
what you've seen with your episodes
you've done with covid you recently i
think it was last week you interviewed
the restaurant owners
some of them have gone viral look here's
here's what you have to realize okay so
you
raising raising kids two different ways
one way extremely disciplined
you better do this you better do that
okay
what is the benefit of raising your kids
discipline they're going to pick up some
of your habits
what is the risk of raising your kids
very disciplined they may
rebel against you okay all right what's
the benefit of raising your kids and
just saying dude just do what
you know like you know what do you want
to do kevin hart's like i want to live
my mom my mom was so disciplined i
couldn't stand it it was all about god
bible all this stuff and i don't want to
live with you
i'm going to go live with my dad he says
i go live my dad my dad's like okay all
right what are you going to do i'll see
you later he says
he never checked on me he never saw what
i was doing he says i had nothing going
on he said he didn't care what time i
came home what time i woke up if i went
to school if i didn't go to school if i
did school my dad could care less what i
did
he says you know what i did i ended up
wanting to go back and live with my mom
because i wanted some order so what's
the point here
if you live with a parent that is
not overbearing on you what's the
benefit you get to do whatever hell you
want to do
what's the disadvantages you get to
screw up and do some stupid things that
somebody couldn't
ruin your life for the rest of your life
okay so
what is the happy medium here i think
that's the real thing what is the happy
medium
it's the happy medium a little bit to
say look dude just keep your word with
me let's have a relationship what do you
want to do
i want to go out no problem you want to
bring your guys you want to do some do
it over here
that i want to go with these guys a
little bit of give and take with the
kids so they can go and do a little bit
of rebel and do what they want to do but
at the same time you have enough
relation with kind of trust with them
okay what is going on today
as far as policies goes is you better
listen to me or else
dude people are going to rebel what are
you talking about state of california
to try to you you're trying to lead your
voters your citizens in a way that you
know what's right and they have no clue
what they're like they can't think for
themselves
what do you mean they can't think for
themselves that's the mom in this case i
think california's being a mom i think
new york's being a mom and i think all
they're doing is they're losing it
they're losing people to other states oh
my gosh they're choosing people
yeah exodus from new york had already
started for the past few years this is
pre-coveted right
so i mean things things were going in
the wrong direction
i mean i was when you compare new york
under giuliani under bloomberg
to what it's been under under de blasio
again pre-covet night and day you don't
want to walk past
heaps of garbage on a hot summer day you
just don't there's nothing
and pay extra you know for the privilege
well can can i can i just follow up with
you on that path yeah i like the analogy
but give me the the dad the kevin hart
dad
state where hey man do whatever the hell
you want buddy but like
there is some downsides to that tell me
what state is doing that right now
that's what i'm asking
what i'm asking you is tell me one state
that's doing that right now
that's just hey do whatever the hell you
want what state is telling you don't
wear a mask
what state is telling you don't social
distance what state is telling you
don't be no it's not florida i'm going
to fort lauderdale by the way no wait a
minute the house i was running in
florida you know what the lady said
getting i'm getting a good-sized house
the lady said you can't have more than
this many people in the house
not even visiting yeah right right now
fort lauderdale county has a
rule going on right now you can't have
more than 10 people in the house that's
fort lauderdale county it's just what
they announced so it's well
it's too safe even track that no what
i'm saying to you is to say that's a
local yeah
to say to say that they don't have
nothing florida's telling you wear masks
florida's telling you to be responsible
florida's telling you to be social
but what do you want to require me to do
you can't enforce me anyways to wear a
mask you can't tell me you better or
else you're going to get arrested well
here here here in texas if you're in a
public place it is mandated that you
have a mask on
really yeah danielle explain the texas
local but if you want to but if i like
public areas but if i go to okay i'll go
to
a restaurant okay that i go to regularly
i'll walk in without a mask in this
restaurant okay
and they're like okay cool come on down
and i'll go sit in the corner they don't
bother me i'm good to go
there is that little bit of look we get
it go sit over here now if i go to yard
house you know what the guy yard house
will say
he's a valuetainer yeah he goes like
what's up pat you you know what i got it
you got to put this mask on so i put the
mask on and i go in we know the
restaurant you go to you're like
if you if you talk to somebody business
owners which you have yeah but a lot of
small business owners are relieved by
mask mandates in public places
because they know that they're going to
get more customers to come through the
door if they know that they're being
rigorous in public places so i tell you
what we did here's what we're doing at
the front when somebody comes in who's
an employee
you get a chance to wear wristband okay
what are the wristbands say can you can
wha what did the three green yellow and
red what is red mean cow
red means don't come near me no
handshakes i'm six feet don't
like completely quarantined stay away
stay away when you wear that wristband
okay what does yellow mean
all right i'm cool with handshakes a
little bit you know elbow elbow
and what does green mean green means
like i don't care right
and guess what that means i've got
immunity yeah but if green meets green
grazer what's up you're green how are
you doing man everything good good but
if you see red hey bro everything good
yeah everything good uh
so you respect it so what happens that's
a safe space and we choose to do that as
a company i thought when the leadership
team made a decision to do that
they brought it to me as a genius idea
guys run with this i love it
even better than what you do and this i
thought that it would wane
but every morning every single employee
here has to take their temperature yeah
so
every morning but that's it that's
mandatory that's a
business thing that we made a decision
to make people
feel safe so what i'm saying to you is
no
state is being fully irresponsible
saying
go at it and do whatever the hell you
want to do no state is going to that
point yes florida may not be
you know state level yeah honestly
localities as you mentioned fort
lauderdale they're making sure that
people want to continue to come but
guess what that means what that tells me
is the governor's saying danielle i
trust you what do you want to do with
your local do this here's what we're
going to do in fort lauderdale awesome
here's what we're going to do in broward
county great here's what we're going to
do miami i respect it go for it
they're empowering the local leaders to
make a decision
amongst their constituents what they're
saying is here's let's hear them out
this is what we're going to be doing now
i've got to tell you i was in the miami
airport recently
and that was freaky i mean i i i thought
i was going to
take a bath in my sanitizing really what
was going on what was going on well
nobody had on their green bands but they
were all acting like it and they were
just
all into each other's business and well
that's what happens in my oh
double kids double peso that was i mean
i was like get me on the airplane
because i'll be safer inside of that tin
can then i'm going to be in this area
outside
yeah it you know the other part culture
that's that's i was about to say
i lived in venezuela when when i see
amore amura and i see each other it's a
kiss on the cheek
okay and i'm more is a you know 50 year
old man i'm a 50 a 40 year old man
kids kids okay it's culturally middle
easterns were a little bit different but
you can't go to an american and say hey
mr jones how are you you know
everything good and you do one of these
hugs that's just not going to give them
like a borax
community it's like you know this is
great they've done actual studies
of the country of italy and found that
because they were so touchy-feely
culturally that's why it got so bad
there yeah i don't disagree
i don't they had to learn how to how to
show affection differently i got to tell
you something what happened last night
which was very interesting for me
yesterday you know we chose the book
winners whoever
bought the books at the beginning we did
something and yesterday we had a private
webinar for these guys and it was
spending an hour with them and just
questions you know back and forth
people from different parts of the
country one person was even on she
she was chosen and she bought the books
didn't speak a
lick of english but she was on because
she's a die-hard valuetainer because she
reads it with the captions on the bottom
nice but she's a cook so we're sitting
there talking and
one of the guys i said tell me your
story so i go to one of these guys and
he's
he listened to tuesday's podcast he says
uh i've been watching you since i was in
high school
17 years old i said okay so how many
years four four five years okay cool
when's your birthday september 23rd tell
me what's going on well i run a this
business
you know makes money selling products
online okay
and he says ever since he says i went to
ohio university on an entrepreneur
program
full ride when i went there i joined the
entrepreneur club that they had on
campus 160 students were part of this
entrepreneur club
and when i went there i said how many of
you guys run a business he says none of
them the only one that did left he says
i'm out of here as well so he leaves
oh he leaves ohio university goes back
he lives in
vermont i believe and he's sitting there
he says for the last eight months
i've been running my business selling
online i said how you feeling
i said how you doing right now he says
i'm an only child he's a listen to the
podcast what you said about being an
only child you know i grew up in an only
child i said okay
i said are you one of the weird ones are
you one of those guys that where people
make fun of you and you're a little bit
weird a little bit different your entire
life he says yes and i'm in that club as
well
so is my son it's a little bit tough
when you ask you're 20 years old you're
at a rough age
it's very hard because you're trying to
figure yourself out i said but
how you doing being by yourself right
now he says pat miserable
this kid was suicidal yesterday okay so
i'm talking to this guy
and i said hey i just want you know
everything's going to be all right like
don't overreact
what's going on right now things are
going to get better i said you got to go
out there and talk to people you can't
be just isolated like this all by
yourself
he says do you remember this reaction i
said you can't be like this i
how many minutes did he cry honestly how
long did he cry i don't know
you know you know when you're on the oh
on the zoom
for everyone to see in front of
everybody this 20 21
i'm feeling like my body hurts a lot
watching this guy
like this guy is ready to just like what
is life what he's asking those types of
questions
weapons conversation and then i'm
sitting there saying okay
i see him i see my son my son is kind of
like
his personality where he's going to be a
techy type of guy and i'm like yeah and
i'm looking there saying
dude this kid needs to know everything's
going to be all right but the guy's
isolated
you got no relationships you got no
people around you you're being told what
to do
following the laws you're thinking
you're being a good citizen but i can't
sit there and say how you guys
like even here the other day we're
talking right say you're going through
an issue
you're going through an issue and you
say hey kai what's up what's up how you
doing yeah you know it's just you know
it is what it is man my girl and i just
went through a bad breakup
oh bro i'm sorry to hear that that i'm
sorry to hear that
took 20 pounds off your back yeah
somebody heard you out
a little bit of empathy so i think i
think the part i'm trying to say is
you're being a disciplined dad what's
the price extreme rebellious
you're being a too liberal dad hey your
kids can go out there and do stupid
things
i think there's a part of it we have to
also understand that people need to be
around people there's got to be a little
bit of camaraderie
follow rules and guidelines but i'm
sorry man to sit around being isolated
there's a lot of consequences to that as
well and that generation
i mean that generation is the first
generation to grow up completely
where you don't have to converse where
you can all on your phone
you can do you can text your entire life
and that's
but i mean but you never learn you know
how
how relationships work if you're doing
everything in a vacuum
but here's a guy but here's a guy that
was
pre-pandemic but during pandemic he's
followed the guideline and he's been
locked in a basement for eight months
to make sure he is being a good citizen
right and he says i'm in vermont
vermont's extremely liberal i have to
follow the guidelines they got here
he says i'm thinking about leaving this
place i said you got to be around people
bro
i said you got to be i'm not telling you
go party get hammered get drunk so you
got to be around some people you got to
go
you know be around some people to talk
to them we need
relationships we need interaction we
need camaraderie we need
a release i can't tell you how many
executives
it was 2012 2013 when i was building a
business and at one point i'm like we're
about to go out of business i have no
clue what the hell i'm doing
we're about to go out of business i put
my half a million dollars at 29 years
old into the business that i had saved
up working in the financial loans i'm
like dude this is what we're going to do
and then at 2012 i'm like i'm running
out of money i got 13 000
on a mac 2011 2012. i'm like i can't
talk to my wife because she's pregnant
she had the first miscarriage we just
talked about it earlier you know
you know apparently adam just found out
for the first time that 74
percent of first pregnancies you have a
miscarriage and you know
one of many things you don't know that
they don't tell you before getting
married which
there needs to be a book saying 200
things they don't tell you prior to
getting married that would be your next
book
i don't think 200 would quite cover up
that but okay
that's a good starting point written by
pbd and
i know
so you sit there and you're thinking
this and you're like okay so
you know a miscarriage so i'm saying i'm
like who do i talk i can't talk to my
dad because my dad's gonna be like i
told you you know you shouldn't have
done this
you can't talk to your friends because
your friends are like wow we knew this
was going to be hard why'd you do it
you can't you can't talk to anybody so
you know what i said i said dude
i wouldn't hire a therapist you did oh
absolutely i found this guy
he was terrible but you know what he was
good at you know just listening
he was dead he never said anything i
tell you every time he's like
so how was your week yeah said i would
go for one hour just bitching
and it's like i'm telling you not
one time did he give me advice says okay
i'll see you two weeks from now
okay that was funny that was it but you
needed a sounding board
you needed a sounding board you found a
sound i found it and i i would leave the
place i'm like what a freaking
stupid job this guy sits there seriously
you went back over but i went back
because i just
needed that release of an hour sitting
telling a person i remember one time i
did relationship issues and all and
correct me if i'm wrong danielle
women just want to vent and you just
have to listen
so i remember i would always try to
solve my girls problems well look you
tell that girl that this is how you want
to operate
and you tell you're not going to stand
for this no no we want you to listen we
don't want your hands
and i just realized that all i have to
do is like no way
sir yeah stop it no way
go on like that's all that's all listen
she did
are a qualified therapist you're in the
wrong business you should go be a
therapist
but but the difference with you is the
difference with you is
you actually are curious so you would
not be the best therapist because you
asked questions
tell me why that happened yeah yeah so
but for him he's just kind of like hmm
yeah
got it okay i i'm i'm thinking about i'm
smelling a meme coming up right now
like tony soprano insert ppd's ahead
the therapist is already working on it
if it's already posted up somewhere
so the
that's i understood isolation in a level
of a business where i can't
go complain to my wife because my wife
is dealing with certain set of issues on
her own
i can't go to friends i can't go to
family i can't go to my sister i can't
go to my buddies i can't go to my board
i can't go to my carries i can't you
can't so in a situation like that you
need somebody to go
so now think about how many people are
going through that right now with kobe
yeah oh gosh
think about how many people are going
through it right now in the last week
eight hundred and eighty five thousand
have have filed uh tell us what that
means instead of the 815.
so last week we had a spike up in
jobless claims to eight hundred and
forty five thousand oh my gosh what's
happening well it's probably a temporary
blip
because california's shut down blah blah
blah just an anomaly
so economists this week we're saying you
know when when the when the data hit at
7 30 this morning they were like it's
going to go back down to 815
000 instead it popped up to 885 000
and when you add up all of the different
programs that were
that were legislated because of the
cares act you know we've gone from 19
million
in one week to 20 and a half million
this week
all the people in the united states
collecting unemployment insurance
benefits
that is something that a lot of people
uh that gives a lot of people shame
they don't want to talk to people about
it and they'll isolate
because economic hardship is something
that by definition
you don't want to talk to people about
you don't want to talk to your close
ones
about i'm struggling you know it's
christmas is coming i can't afford to
put trees underneath it
and so you know it's this is
i really am hoping that 2021
brings in you know you were a successful
entrepreneur once
you lost your business you know what
here's a program
instead of paying you to not work here's
a program to help you
jump start your entrepreneurial life
again
start a new business again because now
people can come to you
i want to see this i don't want to
become a nation
of five stocks in the s p 500
that are out in silicon valley and big
box retailers yeah there's no soul there
yeah and what's it going to do to the
entrepreneurship of this country because
that's the backbone
small business is the backbone so i mean
i want for our politicians in dc to pull
their heads out of
the sand go there danielle um and and
put some
programs out there that re-skill the
workforce okay fine so all the retailers
are closed
you know brick and mortar fine get a new
skill
do a new job spend if you want to spend
trillions of dollars
don't do the new green deal why don't
you fix the potholes and the falling
bridges
and repair the infrastructure nationwide
and by the way the 100 plus thousand oil
and gas workers who've lost their jobs
they're ready to work tomorrow i mean i
want to see our politicians
be smart and help people who want to
start businesses
and have good work ethics be able to
find opportunities instead of paying
people
to be isolated and sit in their homes
and collect unemployment
sorry is this what's the difference
between what
essentially you're suggesting versus
what's going on in congress right now
right now they're thinking about a 900
uh billion dollar stimulus 600 stimulus
checks
there are 10 million americans so of
that 20 million
plus pool of americans collecting
unemployment insurance about
half of them are gig workers they're
they're
they're contract workers they're
self-employed they're people who
don't qualify for state unemployment
insurance programs
they don't pay into the unemployment
insurance fund so they never qualified
for jobless claims in the first time
in the first place the cares act
extended jobless benefits to this
big chunk of the workforce i mean we've
become a gig economy in many ways
all of that expires on december the 26th
so the only thing
it's time for christmas the only thing
that this bill is doing is
it's going to it's going to extend that
it's going to extend the rental eviction
moratorium
because you read about i mean right now
there is a
a lot of the people who are at risk of
being evicted are single single working
mothers
i mean that i mean you have to have
family to fall back on to take in you
and your kids and there's probably going
to be a 6 700
stimulus check in there as well which
will give a boost to the economy but
it's not going to
address any of the fundamental
underlying issues and that's
a band-aid that's what you're saying it
is a band-aid yeah that's all that's all
it is but what could they really do in a
situation like this when both sides are
kind of divided and the fact that we
can't even get these guys on the same
page to agree on
just send a check you think they're
going to sit there and negotiate on how
to get people to
how to make this money in a way that
it's not just a handout being given to
people
if they haven't gotten a reality check
because
unemployment is going up again in
america so
if people aren't really angry this close
to the election
at the people in congress who have been
fighting
and backbiting this whole time instead
of doing their jobs
then something completely wrong i mean
this this is this is the stuff
of this this is a different kind of
of uprising that you're talking about
because a lot of these people have
not lost their incomes by
any of their own doing as we've just
been i agree
i totally been talking about so look
georgia is
you know i have to say the georgia
runoff elections on january the 5th
i'm going to say this out loud they're
more important than the presidential
election
they are they're that important how
close is it
right now it's neck and neck and for
both races
for both races and there's money pouring
couple hundred million
there's money pouring in from all over
the country
because these two races are effectively
a referendum on socialism
so are you know if you keep the senate
read then you can negotiate
i think for smarter programs if you get
this blue wave
and the senate flips to the democrats
and the democrats control the house and
the senate
and the administration and they start to
legislate in universal basic
income again these are programs
that are designed to pay people to not
work well
no problem pride in that say it's
january 6 we wake up
the you know liberals win both okay
so now it's 50 50 with the tie breaker
going to kamala harris right
say that all of a sudden kamala harris
has power exactly
exactly and kamal kamala's more left
than biden is
more way some caller further left than
even sanders but let's just say she's
more left than biden is right let's just
keep keep that part
january 6 they win both what happens
you get chatter about the new green deal
i mean you're talking about tell me
chatter versus execution because chatter
has been going on
do you think things will be executed of
course so give me what things would be
executed
we are talking about health care for
everybody we are talking about
universal basic income we are talking
about
the idea of paying people to be out of
work
for ever and that is just so
anti-american we are not
we we have no reason to to vote
socialism into law
and kiss our economy goodbye and watch
china
rise up because i can guarantee you that
if china is in any way
interfering with this election it is
pouring money into those two democratic
candidates
period end full stop because if we go
socialist
that is the nail in the coffin of
capitalism and we can
kiss our reserve currency status goodbye
the greenback will no longer have
hegemony on the world stage all of these
and we get inflation by the way
and we get inflation because we stop
worrying about debt and deficits
when people running the country don't
think that there's any consequence
for a 10 trillion dollar 2021 2022
spending spree so it's basically dogs
and cats
living together it's anarchy but but
let's go there okay let's just say it
happens
okay and let's just see we have to yeah
i want to go there let's just say
universal basically can come
passes and andrew yang becomes uh uh
you know he's already said he's
potentially running for mayor of new
york city no no
okay so is a half dozen other people we
can name yes but yes
yes well by the way he's a he's a
credible name to run let's just just
just just yeah yeah so
your valuables the right one so so but
let's just say we're there
january 6th happens and then at this
point of the game
everyone calls biden now that you have
it aoc you know
the whole defense we got to make climate
change a part of that budget next
is the universal basic income it's next
medicare for all
health care for all unemployment
benefits extended
you know uh uh extreme regulation
extreme censorship
everyone a possible uh uh court packing
that we can raise it from
seven to nine to eleven to thirteen to
fifteen let's just say we go there
the sky's the limit but let's just say
we go there
you know the the part that i want to ask
and i i ask
i ask larry arn who's the president of
hillsdale college which i don't know if
you're familiar with hillsdale college
they're one of the oldest universities
it's conservative you know they've had
some incredible people that have gone to
that university
and they get also a lot of criticism
because they're in michigan i think
they're in michigan
uh uh kai can you check to see where
they're based out of i think they're out
of michigan so they're you know they're
dealing with the governor whitmer you
know all that other stuff
the question i ask is the reagan quote
thank you the ranking quote which is
what we're all one generation away from
losing
our freedom okay we're one generation
away from losing our freedom okay
that's true today well that's what i
want to ask
is it is it that scary to say oh my gosh
we will never have what we had here
because once we go here's a tipping
point you can't ever go back to it
or is it just another time where people
are just overly
panicking and using their panic to make
sure people vote on the right okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna play socrates here for a
minute go forward have you ever seen
any government program rolled out that
was then rolled back
great question i agree with you i agree
with you
and you are by the way but can you ask
that one more time no no it's very
important can you ask that one more time
have you ever seen a government program
rolled out that was not rolled back you
mean social security medicare and
medicaid i mean there's 81 try canceling
social security there's 81
different they try to talk about what
she's saying about that i'm talking
about the 81 different social programs
and under the obama administration you
had the the quietest stealthiest
expansion of the social safety net in
u.s history because the federal reserve
slammed interest rates down to zero
percent and allowed the company
the company country if we ran it like a
company it would be a different country
no doubt about it but
but allowed the debt to be run up
magnificently
so that that that set the stage for
where we are but
none of those programs have been even
reformed
much less rolled back and you
you're delivering a message to children
you're saying
you're saying all that student debt
let's just take that 1.78 trillion
dollars let's just expunge it
i mean how does that make people like me
feel who had to work their asses off to
pay off their student debt not so good
but you're teaching young americans an
unamerican way of life
is it something you think that they
would implement
all the above meaning cancel social
security medicare for all new green
deals
okay this this like so here we go here's
my follow-up question
so i can set you up danielle hey i don't
in my opinion maybe some of that gets
done i don't think all of it get done
i'd like to hear it because of the house
okay and that's my next question it
cannot because of the house so
that's my next question is where do the
midterm elections come into this
immediately the midterm elections are
already in play because they have
dragged their feet on this stimulus bill
in the dead of winter so how can play
though
you have to go back 20 years to find
as slim as a majority as we have right
now
in the house of representatives there
was
a quiet gop revolution
heading into this presidential election
you have to go back
20 years to find a congress with a
slimmer and it was it was a gop congress
at the time
but they had the slimmest margin
pelosi's got an even slimmer
margin than that so independents
moderate democrats are going to be
easily swayed
if you start to see some of socialism
tight light legislation fast
you're going to see democrats and
independents cross the aisle
and vote against elections
that's what people don't appreciate is
the house is not locked and
because because of the slimness of the
majority because so many
seats in the house of representatives
flipped to the geo even
senators like my my guy joe manchin in
west virginia he's already come out and
said look like
i'm a red state democrat in in in west
virginia
i'm not just gonna tow the senate line
i'm gonna
so i think that's something that is
gonna be very unique i think we we
understand that biden is going to be the
president i said it
i think people are going to be willing
to negotiate
and broker deals and cross the line and
yeah but what i'm what i'm thinking
and you do all that but it's a whole
different dynamic than what we've been
using here's where i'm going
to here's where i'm going to what
leverage does the right have
if they win the if they win senate what
level so you come to the negotiating
table what leverage do you have
what's your leverage for that two years
before midterms
the republicans you're republican you
don't have a ton of leverage
right what leverage do you have but
remember
biden ran on a platform that he was
going to be a president of the entire
country
everyone says that though and then obama
said that in his campaign
if kamala harris doesn't gain the upper
hand well she will though because if
senate wins
both then she if it does if it does not
because you just said what if the senate
stays ready no no no okay i'm sorry i'm
so what i was trying to say is
say they lose the senate and it's 50 50.
then it's a crap what
what leverage do republicans have very
very little what would it be actually
what would it be
you're at the negotiating table you're a
republican well you know we're this
we're not going to wait
until 2022 we'll show you okay no
problem well
that whole thing you're saying that they
have so your midterms will be decided
the
minute any kind of legislation gets
passed
it is socialism what social program has
ever been reverted back away
you got two years to pass anything you
want to pass so what leverage do you
have
whatever you pass i mean obamacare
passed and then
trump tried to you know do anything to
it what happened to trump
you don't care about this and you don't
jimmy kimmel coming out and saying you
know this and
everybody coming out yeah you are like a
terrible human being about uh trying to
reverse obamacare
the risk i think is that
if you get this blue wave so you're
you're anticipating massive deficits and
rising taxes
i mean you could put the economy into a
tailspin what kind of taxes when you say
rising taxes
at the federal level capital gains taxes
think about all of the gains people are
sitting on in
in the stock market right now and what
would happen
what the trickle-down effect would be i
mean we ran a graphic cool intelligence
a few days ago that shows that ceo
confidence
lags the s p 500 by one quarter in other
words ceos make decisions about head
count based on where their share
based on where their stock is trading so
just imagine that short-term thinking
you mean
very short-term thinking but yet they're
the ones that are that that are in
charge of
the pink slips let me ask you a question
you said something and i don't want to
skip over that you said massive deficits
and also uh taxes i think taxes isn't
the whole
point of tax increases to limit the
massive deficits to try to balance
budgets oh i tell me about that it will
be an apples and oranges
situation complete apples and oranges
you will have billionaires pick their
asses up and leave the country
think about the exodus to florida and
texas and the number of companies
in the last week that have relocated
taxes you're saying not only
leave i'm saying they're state they're
out bye-bye
and what happens to those people do they
not pay taxes do they renounce their
citizenship like what act
like go there as pat likes to say what
happens if they leave the country
these americans that just i'm out i'm
going to
i mean you can't you can renounce your
your your
your citizenship if you want if you're
if you're an expat you still have to
file
taxes in the united states of america
you get a credit in the country in which
you live
so where are they going to would they
why wouldn't they just go to puerto rico
at that point
you're still in america but you know you
don't have to pay income taxes okay now
you've you've stumped me i can't i can't
do the puerto rico i stopped danielle di
martino booth what
this is i think i alarmed the 420 state
thing that they have you only pay four
percent in taxes for 20. i have friends
in miami that have gone to puerto rico
straight up it's uh and now you know
puerto rico has become a tax haven a lot
of private equity guys hedge fund guys
he that's what he's saying yeah that's
what he's saying so so
other countries you're saying that in
the uh you're getting me ready for my
saturday evening bar mitzvah i'm just
letting you know
you're getting me in the mood so so then
let's transition into the net by the way
we've got a lot of different topics here
to cover i mean
topics that we have retail sales drop
one point one percent november biggest
on seven months
and october was revised down to a
negative i saw that yeah facebook
accuses apple of anti-competitive
behavior which we'll talk about tom
cruise lost his mind
which maybe we'll talk about that
because adam is so excited about that
story
you got to hear that you got to hear
this will ceos mandate
employees to take vaccines 72 percent in
ser
in the survey said they're open to it
bitcoin cracks 20 000 for the first time
23 today 23 000 massachusetts regulators
slam
robin hood for uh uh being reckless and
focusing on you know uneducated uh
investors biden's thinking about getting
igaron as an ambassador as well as
katzenberg and iger is pretty excited
about it
and open to it and then you have
republican north carolina state senator
trump should
invoke the insurrection which is a
little bit strange to want to uh uh
invoke that
texit strategy uh we'll we'll cover that
trump's mar-a-lago neighbors are taking
legal action to try to force him to live
elsewhere pete budaje transportation uh
uh
uh uh what do you call it secretary yeah
secretary
uh and then a few other things that's
going on here
uh that we can cover but i want to talk
about texas
what do you think about the idea of
texas texas so
let me give some let me give some color
to it so
we can uh cover how this conversation
came about with texit
um the word text it succession and texas
are being mentioned more frequently
and by actual politicians the supreme
court's
dismissal of the texas lawsuit against
four other states regarding presidential
election has the lone stars
state republican chairman alan was
suggesting a u.s split
earlier in the week texas state
representative kyle biederman
tweeted out that he plans to file
legislation to give texans a vote for
texas to reassert
its status as an independent nation the
movement for texas to leave the union
has been dubbed
texted thoughts
well i'm against it period end so i'll
put that out there
uh that being said if you're talking
pure economics here
our borrowing costs would likely be
lower than the nation as a whole
we have one of the most diverse
economies in the country
dallas itself is the number one
commercial real estate
market in the nation today uh
we are the largest exporting state in
the nation we export more
than california we're the second largest
economy
in the country and we have an
infrastructure
that is second to none in terms of
the capacity and capability of being
economically
independent as a nation we do texas does
texas does yes if you're asking me on
paper
yeah absolutely why won't it make sense
to do like what would be the negative
like you know the whole brexit you're
looking at brexit if you have a brexit
you know with a citizenship you can go
live in norway you can go live there you
know if you do brexit then you can't do
that so a lot of people that are working
ticket it's going to hurt some
businesses people and
london are going to take it headquarters
is going to move out of london they're
going to have to go elsewhere so
when you actually go deeper into brexit
you kind of see the pros and cons of it
and i know it's 5149 type of number that
they're talking about 53 47. so there's
an r if any time it's that number
both sides have a reasonable argument
why they want and they don't want to do
it right
why would be an argument for texas to do
it
you said you said those benefits but why
would be the benefit for them not to do
it why should they want to stay
in the union what's the benefit okay
okay so why
are companies relocating from california
to texas
they want to be part of the united
states of america
but in a business-friendly state got it
so they don't want to be isolated they
don't want to be penalized
for because you know that great britain
will be there there will be penalties
sure but that is not country companies
are not relocating to texas
in mass because they think texas is
going to secede from the united states
of america
it doesn't happen that way i totally
agree and i'm a patriot by the way
so i like our flag yeah i i stand for
our flag
and again my boys go to a military
academy they stand for the flag
texas benefits by being part of the
united states that is attractive to be
in
it makes our economy roar it
it gives us you wouldn't have the same
dynamic if texas was not part of the
united states
you wouldn't let me plus i can't wait
until we're
until the economy of texas is larger
than that of california so i want to
stick around just to see that
you said something the other day and and
you know something that you even said
you great analogy or metaphor what do
you have the two parents right one
parent is super strict one's parent is
super lenient
something that you know i'm hearing with
different opinions and
a quote or a
saying that i think uh reverberates is
you know
uh the truth is usually lie somewhere in
the middle right where if there's two
different opinions the truth
typically lies somewhere in the middle
so for me when i hear texas wants to
secede
emotionally i'm thinking that's
treacherous that's ridiculous that's
treason you're going to leave the united
states of america that's why we fought
the civil war that's freaking ridiculous
like you you know blasphemous like
emotional
logical you know you pointed out
something the other day it's like well
you know maybe for lower taxes and it's
like at what point
does it make sense like at what point
would you say i can't deal with this
anymore
tax-wise whatever but again i'm going to
just revert back to the truth is
somewhere in the middle so i know you
have an interesting opinion on this but
for me emotionally it's it's so absurd
to even
think about emotionally but logically
it's like well there might be some
benefits
here's how i process this daniel this is
how i process this
i think the best thing that happened to
coffee drinkers
after they were paying five bucks to
starbucks is coffee bean
i think dunkin donuts started becoming a
great thing because their coffee was
what 99 cents a buck 19.
more dunking donuts in new york city
than starbucks there you go yeah that's
right so
so then you saw mcdonald's came out
remember when mcdonald's came out with
the coffee like six years ago five years
ago i was like go try to mcdonald's
coffee it's ridiculous
starbucks drinkers are like dude this is
actually good mcdonald's coffee i don't
go to mcdonald's but i go to mcdonald's
for coffee
who won it who won there the consumer
one right the reality is who won is the
consumer right and starbucks had to get
their act together
okay so you work for a company and they
say well our benefits we offer this
well we're not going to offer those
benefits we're not going to give you
401k match and we're not going to give
you health insurance you go figure it
out
i'll go over here it's okay this other
oh you know what no we are going to
offer 401k we are going to offer health
insurance we are going to offer okay
great
so this is this is a competition that's
why amazon hires people so quickly
they're going to pay them 15
an hour and give them health insurance
there you go so the point i'm trying to
make to you is
who is america's competition locally if
people in america want to leave where do
they go
i think there needs to be a place for
america want to leave like for example
right now what america has
is say say the two
the state uh senators georgia goes
left and kamala is essentially a major
decision maker in america no more ribbon
cutting
no more ribbon cutting right if that
happens what do you mean by ribbon
cutting
i mean she's got a she has a sort of
position you know she has a vice
presidential position
unless you mean like actual things that
you're saying she's one of the most
powerful vps we've had
powerful vps she becomes one of those
powerful people in the world yeah
dude this is not a joke like georgia yes
yes so she is now
you know the second most powerful
deciding she's the sec
she's a top five most powerful person in
america in the world so it's going to be
biden g and she's talking joe biden is
true to his word about being a moderate
and being a president i don't
i don't think it's gonna happen i don't
think it's gonna happen so here's here's
how i process it
the only way i process it is okay
uh oracle's moving to texas great better
than where they are right now
elon musk moved to uh to uh uh austin
great you know joe rogan moved to
austin healed packard moving here
goldman sachs is
moving their trading side to miami you
got uh
the not carl icahn the other billionaire
carl icon also florida singer yes that
peter
paul singer paul singer moved over there
as well okay great
so so that's moving from a state you're
not happy
to another state i'm all about but now
where do i go if i'm not happy with the
country
when your federal income taxes are going
up now federal income tax where now
you're paying 60
the federal income tax goes to 60
percent not where you're going so
federal income tax goes to 60
top line revenue you're making a million
bucks you pay 60 percent of that you
keep
500 of it your tax dollars are going to
bail out all the blue states that
100 percent so now watch this so you
make a million something
that's so much money you're not making a
million you're really going to end up
making 400 and then if you're living in
a state that's charged another 10
percent
so then you you're gonna end up being
stuck with three hundred thousand dollar
income
give or take say three and the whole u.s
economy will slow down as well so your
property taxes are going up no matter
where you live
so so if that happens where do i go do i
go to new zealand
do i go to new zealand is a rock star i
know they are that's where we go
do i go to new zealand do i go to do i
go to panama
do i go to you know canada i mean
there's
there's always canada well you don't
mind the cold if do i go to canada do i
where do i go so i i think the the way
i'm processing it
i'm processing it as i think it would be
actually
a good thing for the american voters
if texas became a country because now
you have and texas is a big land
plenty of room plenty of room to expand
it's not a small place
you got a lot of if you drive in texas
you can drive for six hours and you
don't see nothing
you can drive you're still in the state
of town and you're still in the state of
texas so meaning
there's plenty of room for expansion
there's plenty of room for all those
couple more questions yeah
go over your processor yeah i've i've
got a big hole to poke and what you're
talking about
here we go a couple different go for it
all right so number one if you're like
i'm a texan now no more america okay
number one first question that comes to
mind what happens to electoral college
because the
republicans cannot win the uh
yes the they cannot win without texas of
course i mean
how many okay i agree all right so
republicans will never win a
presidential election ever
i agree okay what happens to people who
are living in texas who are like dude
i want to live in america i mean i don't
i get it you have the choice then cool
i'm an american
so what happens to everybody in texas
are you no longer american you are no
longer american i'm just texan
that's it i don't i'm not a member i'm
not a citizen of the united states
i'm not american i'm just straight up
texan like how far do we go
like what happens with elections what
happens with electoral college what
happens with i'm american
like uh-huh and what happens to all of
those federal
dollars that the state of texas gets to
handle its social programs
and what are the what are the carrying
costs and the overhead mr businessman of
running a country i think
i think we're forgetting something here
here's what we're forgetting
i think we're forgetting that the
innovators and the job creators
sometimes just want to be left alone and
the innovators and job creators
want to go to a place where they can
continue to innovate
and job create without being suffocated
you know the idea of suffocation to
someone who wants to be free is very
very important i mean if you've
i lived in iran you know can you imagine
telling you kids never tell anybody
we're christians okay when you go out
there don't tell people you're
christians just say i don't know what
religion we are you know
don't tell anybody or christians when
you go out there be careful when you do
can you imagine having to give your kids
you already tell your kids don't talk to
strangers don't talk to this don't
imagine all the stuff that you tell your
kids
add 40 other things they have to tell
your kids when they go out there if
somebody pulls up their mother
the hezbollah posey if this happens if
that happens if this happens okay
so eventually the job creators in iran
you know how people say oh iranians are
so rich oh they're such great business
people it's not that they're great
business people it's the business people
that left iran
that came here the ones that are not
business people some of them decided to
stay
like oh yeah i'm getting the hell out of
here so it's not like all iranians are
great business people the business
people left iran and they came and they
went to santa monica
for nine years he taught me all about
running a business there you go they're
great business people right so
look at that the point i'm trying to
make to you is i think
i think the job creators are not that
worried about it
i think the people that would worry
about it are those
who have the jobs those who have family
in other states
those who love the idea of america but
if the idea of america
say america what is the idea of america
actually go there what is the idea of
america
and if we go in the direction with
georgia all this stuff
then the idea of america is no longer
the idea of america it's still named
america but it's no longer america so
that's the point i'm trying to make you
when i come to america i didn't come to
america you could take the name out and
you can say there's 50 countries in the
world for you to choose from to raise
your kids in
all the names are you don't know it's
sweden norway mexico anything it just
tells you the benefits of each state and
what freedoms you have
you don't say i want to go oh it's a
beautiful name i'm going to go to
america no you say
i'm going to go to this country with
these benefits which one is this i'll
reveal this state oh it's america okay
i'll go to america
that's how families made the decision
they don't just say i love
how great of a name america people come
to america for the idea so if the
idea that the founders came up with is
no longer relevant today
what the hell am i doing living in this
idea that's no longer relevant i'm going
to go to another place
that now is saying these are the ideas
that we have in our country are you
saying that
at the end of the day this all comes
down to taxes
everything no i didn't say taxes taxes
no i didn't i didn't say that buddy i
didn't say that listen
it's not it's not taxes it's not just
taxes i want to be left alone
i want to be able to have an opinion i
want to be able to say something you
totally disagree with me and say you
have no clue what the hell you're
talking i want to have discourse
i want to sit down and be comfortable
knowing that i can have an opinion
that's opposing that
in texas now but part of the united
states
can't you do that in florida i can't do
that anywhere for that matter if it's
based on the ideas that america was
started on
yes freedom of speech freedom of
assembly
freedom of you know second amendment
freedom if i have those ideas then yes
so i think i think look you you know
where i'm looking at moving next
it's not like i'm sitting here telling
you i'm going to be a texan the rest of
my life so i'm not
all i'm saying is i actually think it's
very good for americans if texas becomes
its own country
oh so you would vote for texan to
succeed
is that what you're saying i don't think
you heard what i said
okay guys guys let's let's play domino
one more time yeah this is a terrible
idea of georgia doesn't happen and we
don't flip all the way to the other side
okay it's a terrible idea but if georgia
happens
and it's 50 50 you've got kamala biden
two years to add a million and one
social programs that you can't say
nothing about and they're not going to
sit there and say you can't do anything
for me to increase court packing i can
increase it to 9 11
13 15 and own that forever so roast
again
i'm gonna push back you have to
understand that five
people is not a heavy majority
the house is not insured
the house is not bright blue the house
is
a shade the house is purple let me ask
you a question let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question
how often do you notice that
like supreme court you know the supreme
court folks that we have right
trump brought how many of them in three
of them in how many of them voted for
them to go to a recount with the other
four
how many of them how many did three none
zero yeah what's the point
republican justices
will vote based on certain values and
principles
their loyalty is to the values and
many times democratic justices will vote
on their loyalty of their party it's a
big difference
on values and prince i don't know if i'm
making sense on what i'm saying here
so we're saying one of them is a
constitutional
purist yeah that's what i'm saying so a
constitutional empire is going to be
like look i i
appreciate you trump thank you for
putting me in but dude i don't agree
with you
because it goes we just had a real live
test yeah that was so
that's respect to these justices for
saying all right
sorry buddy of course but that's not the
case with folks
on the other side well they don't have
the majority you're saying but it
doesn't matter historically they're
always going to vote against republican
supreme court yes
so so if you go to congress historically
historically
more right is open to
well you know what i think it's fair
let's talk about this
then left is to say i'm willing to
reason with you
the right is willing to reason more than
the left is willing to reason
the left is not willing to you can sit
there and give an argument they're not
going to sit there and say you know what
pat you're making a good point you know
yeah
you're right you know i'm not going to
pass this bill to raise the capital
gains to 39.6 because it's going to hurt
the economy
nope i'm going to be loyal to my party
it's a difference between loyalty or
party versus loyal to certain values so
i am going to throw something else out
there
there is one overriding factor that
motivates all politicians because
remember the democrats used to be the
party of the people
and that's changed who gets more money
off wall street
the democrats so there is one
overarching
theme that we're leaving out here and
that's lobbyist
and money but here's also what you're
leaving out what what the other part
you're leaving out
is who is the source of delivering
the messaging of that to the american
people
the media who controls the media 99
is the left so if the messaging is going
from that direction i can spin the story
like the article came out the other day
saying biden's
approval rating of the people today is
above 60
by the hill how do you measure that
today
above 60 percent and so imagine if i'm
somebody that doesn't follow
politics and i'm like you know what i
knew i knew i voted right look people
like this guy already this is great
so the naive voter is just going to be
like okay go good oh okay the night vote
is going to say
oh all right got it so yeah the the
democrats have historically been for the
people who are maybe not the wealthiest
but why are they getting money from wall
street
oh they're getting there because they're
trying to control them so they're not
going to do
there is it's all on messaging
everything is on messaging so
but i i do think that the banks
have a lot i think jamie diamond is i
think jamie dimon is one of the most
powerful people in america i really
really do and i think that the big banks
yes and i think that the big banks would
not
cotton to socialism in america
why did they vote that way though oh
they
uh if you listen to a an interview that
jamie dimon
made he basically said he basically
said what biden is saying that he's
going to stay down the middle
right so so which happens by the way as
long as the senate doesn't flip daniel
there is say say again it goes back to
the argument of
uh you know you're you're working with
somebody and you're being
more than reasonable with this person
but that person no matter what you do
for them
they don't think you're reasonable no
matter what you do for them
they don't think you're reasonable when
do you win with this person
you never win the video you never win
there's no winning with this person
so meaning as much as jamie dimon may be
the most powerful person in america
as much as you know biden campaigned on
i'm going to be the president for all
the people not just you know the left
you know i'm going to be this which was
a great message obama gave the same as
well when he gave this dnc speech in
2004 saying
it's the americas of not about the black
and the white and the
lg it's about the lgbtq community it's
about the
farmers it's about those who believe in
the guns it's about you know
and he gave this message like oh my gosh
this is awesome and then he becomes
president never meets with paul ryan and
everything goes politically on one side
so
messaging and execution are two
different things i agree
all right so for me all i'm saying is
i'm not pitch all i'm saying my domino
my domino on why they ought to consider
it as an option
is if georgia goes full left
and that goes that direction i think
people ought to hear the argument of why
that may not be a bad idea to consider
not saying to do it
i think it should be on the table to
discuss what does it look like you like
uh accountability
not just here's what it is it's not i
like accountability i like competition i
i like competition
a lot because competition is good
for me i need competition okay because
if i don't
if i don't have competition then how am
i innovating how am i getting better how
am i listening if
you don't have competition you actually
don't listen to people you don't listen
to your employees you don't listen to
your partners you don't listen to your
family you don't listen
you you have to have competition
competition is a very healthy thing for
you you need it right and now we've got
one in five american companies it's the
walking dead
so as much a big company as much as we
talk about made in china 2025 and china
is going to be bigger than u.s by 2025
and here it is
it is if we do all these things yeah as
much as we talk about that but here's
the question
how as let's just say china passes
america how many americans are going to
wake up and say that's it
i'm going to china nobody it's not going
to be
i'm going to china yeah but all four of
my kids take mandarin
in case we ever have to deal with them
there's a difference between dealing
with them
with them and moving would you move your
family to china
okay so there's a difference between
communicating and doing that right
okay so all i'm saying is if something
happened to america
where it flipped far far far in one
direction politically
yeah what's your plan b where are you
going i hear wuhan is lovely this time
right especially oh my gosh you just
said that again out loud
so so let me give a quick shout out to a
couple people roger uh
uh the seeker 2020 uh uh
roger var had to pay 25 000 exit 25
tax to be released from citizenship he
was the bitcoin early promoter
uh 50 was given by sean nicholson how
will biden's u.s
deal with current trade war and rapid
deterioration ties between australia and
china
and other to punish australian by using
australians
heavy reliance towards chinese uh trade
to try to hurt australians maybe we'll
go to that
in a second because the guy get 50 bucks
we'll go to that and then we had sean
nicholson that just gave
99 cent he just wanted to make sure he
winked at atom
which that's just dude that's just love
right there can't even get a dog
then let me get a couple dollars greasy
why said danielle needs to come back
more often we love
danielle and collins motto said pbd can
you shout out officer fuller
for giving me a ticket for not
completely stopping at a stop sign in
the middle of nowhere
with no traffic around okay
officer fuller we need local revenue
here
what do you have to say about the china
australia deal with look again i i
i think that people cannot discount the
fact that
i mean i i spent 10 days in australia i
gave i gave a speech over there it is an
amazing country beautiful people
dynamic economy all dependent
not all that's too strong very dependent
on china
australia the biggest port in in
australia
china has a 50-year lease an island i
stay on i i stayed on china owns
i mean the the buildings that have gone
up
chinese developers so for australia to
lead 116
countries 116 countries demanding that
the world health organization
investigate launch an independent
inquiry into the origins of the virus
for australia to be in the lead
they knew that they were putting their
their economy
at grave risk and boy have they gotten
some blow back
huge blowback i mean forget wine don't
get me wrong love australian shiraz
lovely good
yum but forget the wine they've china's
now crossed the line and said
cold so i mean they're they're talking
about hitting the australian economy
where it hurts australia is a staunch
ally of the united states
staunch stone staunch biden has
initially said he's not moving those
tariffs
on china oh you heard what he said
yesterday though he says i'm going back
and i'm open to the idea of having to
remove tariffs to
uh uh grow the economy so he's willing
to entertain the idea is that a bad
thing
is that a bad thing okay wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait no no no no now you're having
two different conversations because the
tariffs have hurt
a lot of our manufacturers yes very
badly
but what i'm what i'm not talking about
the the efficacy of tariffs or not
i'm talking about standing behind
australia
and and and defending australia in
situation
given the fact that for the first time
in 30 years they're in recession
uh so they're on their knees and still
standing on principle standing up
against china
so i mean i i take my hats off to
australia right now
that they're that they're doing
something they're being kind of american
i hope it can stay that way where's the
united states
uh in on this who i know we pulled out
or trump pulled out is the united states
weighed in on the united states was not
part
of the 116 countries independent inquiry
and what are your thoughts on that do
you think well i i
think china accountable the united
states i think it had more to do with
the fact that
whether we were in the who or not but i
i absolutely think that an independent
inquiry
still needs to be done yeah and by the
way
why isn't anybody asking about vaccines
in in china you've got an entire country
that's
up and running and nobody's talking
about the vaccine and you're saying that
they're not taking the vaccine
saying that they've probably had a
vaccine and have all taken it
these guys no i'm getting everything
it's just
yeah okay is this another youtube
outage check because youtube had this
issue the other day
are you seeing stuff online youtube is
down or no speedtest.net
sam
let's see if it is best
and we're not even on the wi-fi this is
wi-fi
we're not even connected to wi-fi we're
connected directly
we're saying this this is my phone this
is wi-fi
so we're hardline we're t1 yeah ethernet
will be
okay 400 hearing it and i've seen it but
it just goes back and forward so it goes
back and forth it's saying it's out
that's in it's out that says can hear
better
um youtube has sound because the
commercial before your video has sound
but when you go into your videos
has no sound so no it's not down are we
back
can you can see yeah
i mean we'll just go right now say that
again
it says we're back up okay all right
let's go back to it so you were saying
that how come we're not talking about
the vaccine and the question i ask you
is
what do you think about the ceos 72
percent saying they're open to the idea
of
mandating vaccine for their employees
again
you're asking me a business question so
if this is something that hinders
revenue generating capacity then you can
do whatever you need to do in order to
run your business
but there's no but i didn't say but
you're running a business not a country
i mean americans have free choice to do
whatever they want to do
you have a free choice as to where you
want to work as well
so so then how do you mandate that does
it become
i mean is it does it infringe upon your
liberties that
i think that some companies have dress
codes
well no what i'm saying is but this is
this is what what cause
look okay let's just say i mean i got
employees i go to my place of guys
moving forward everybody's got a vaccine
shot
for me to say it without the state
saying it
you want me to go to my employees and
guys if you don't take vaccine you can't
again it depends
it depends on the business model if
you're if you're some company that
everybody's working from home and you
haven't taken a hit to your
to your sales or your profits there's no
reason to say you but but if you are in
an environment
if you run a meatpacking company and
you've had
outages if you run a manufacturing line
if you're a ford motor company
and you keep having to shut down your
your production lines your assembly
lines
because of covet outbreaks and and if
that's disrupting your your ability to
conduct
business then i think that it is within
your purview
well so as a business owner so if it's
72 that the problem that i'm having this
is the word
requiring and you bring up a good idea
with like meat packing companies for
example i i didn't go there
that means 28 are saying no no we're
good with it
so what happens like walk me down this
path what happens to the actual
employees
hey guys uh you know there's 100 200 500
people here
you're all now required to have a
vaccine uh we're you know you got to pay
for it yourself or we're doing it for
free whatever just
remember there's no liability in this
relief package and then
no liability protections so what happens
to the employees that say no i'm good do
they get fired so you're doing you're
doing cya you're saying look
as an employer if you get covered you
can sue me
because the republicans and the
democrats couldn't come together and
agree on liability protection for
for either customers or but that's what
i'm saying so if you're an employer you
have to cover yourself so if you want to
make sure that your work environment is
coveted free
because any employee can sue you if they
get coveted in their work environment
you can't have it both ways so on your
resume if you're looking for a new job
do you have to put that on the
on your resume yes i've been vaccinated
you know here's my here's my
qualifications weird thing
are you going to fire like are you if
you have 100 people here at home office
i just
20 people you're going to fire people
how does that happen listen let me let
me let me tell you the other day i said
this and people started laughing i said
nowadays
you it's like when you meet somebody i
ask the first question you good with
handshakes
you know are you good with this you tell
me where you're i'm good whatever and
they'll say okay this this that i said
nowadays
you know if you're willing to hug
somebody you're far right
if you're a handshake person you're
republican if you're a
fist-bump person you're center-right if
you're an elbow person
you're left yeah if you don't touch me
don't hug me you're far left
you can tell politics nowadays right
so so then this is where i go but this
is where i go with this here's the next
part the next part then becomes
there there is an element of this that
is about
it's it's becoming a religion meaning
you know do i have to be
we only hire people here that are
pro-life pro-choice we're only hired
people here that are christians we only
hire people that are this we only hire
people that are atheists you can't talk
about no no no no no no no let me just
go there for a second
i see where you're going you can only
work over you if you believe in this you
can only work over you for believing
that
what do you mean i have to take a
vaccine to work at your company
i i don't i don't know about that part
now
if i'm a doctor i get it if i'm a doctor
sure
because i'm dealing with people so maybe
i got to be safe if i'm in a military
your government property whatever they
want to do to your body they can do
because you're officially government
property
so you don't have a choice when you join
the military you chose to get that
600 a month or 800 dollars whatever the
military pays you for an e1 nowadays i
don't know what anyone pays you nowadays
e1 salaries nothing you have to do
whatever we tell you to do
in return we're going to give you this
this this this that but whatever shot we
gave you
for an employer to come out and say if
you don't take the vaccine you can't
work here i don't know so so just think
about it
so so okay so there's a middle ground
here pat
if you're not gonna get vaccinated then
you're gonna agree to never sue me
meaning you have to sign a waiver or a
free of liability form
employee full liability expenses i'm
fully good with that i'm okay with that
i'm actually fully okay with that
because if you say
yeah i don't want to take the vaccine no
problem it's totally fine but if you do
get
something then you have to know that you
can't ever sue me and something happens
yeah i'm good with that but then
how about the other people that do take
the vaccine and they get it from the
person that didn't take the vaccine can
they sue you so
the importance of then you go sue the
vaccine maker
[Laughter]
so and the vaccine maker is going to say
well it's not 100 it's 95
it's 96 that's what we left to four
percent to protect ourselves
so but but you you never did answer my
question if you're if you're
ford motor company if you're if you're
tyson
chicken and you have to stop
business because everybody has to go
quarantine even if it's just seven days
is that fair to the employer if i have
to quarantine for seven days
if you if you have to shut assembly
assembly lines down if your workforce is
out because
they've been in contact with people with
covet so you have to you have to close
business
your your sales are going to go down
your profits are going to take a hit is
that fair to the employer well then i
think no then i think the option would
be
to uh you know the option would be would
the government allow you to say
whoever works here gets paid at this
level
if you work from home you're going to be
a consultant you get paid at this level
what's happening yeah pay cuts
pay cuts for working from home that's
already started yeah pay cuts working
for what was happening
speaking of vaccine uh in covid yeah by
the way we're at some point we're gonna
have to get to tom cruise
my point is the fact that that you can't
you're not going to win everybody
there's no way you're going to win
everybody
the person that loses here is the ceo
the ceo doesn't win
correct the ceo is the one that loses
it's it's an it's a no-win proposition
it's a no
ceo is losing no matter what and if
you're without a ceo because
and if you're a publicly traded i would
just be a customer service
representative
i'm ready to just answer phones but if
you're a pedophile how are you
awesome give me 15 bucks an hour just do
that without the shot but if you're a
publicly traded company what are your
shares
what are your shareholders saying about
using the customer service rep right now
what do your shareholders say to a ceo
because he's unpopular
they say too bad it's your job to
maximize shareholder returns
i don't have problem with that but i
think i think what happens is
this forces more people to
uh triangulate and socialize amongst
each other and say
see i disagreed with the seal now
there's a division in the company now
you don't have the culture now you don't
have cohesiveness now you can't make
advancement
now people are dropping the ball and
that people are cliquish and the clicks
are coming together and i told you he
wasn't right i told you she wasn't right
and then
you have all this other stuff that comes
with it and it's not like it ever
happens at our company but i'm sure some
people experience
some of this stuff yeah i'm just kind of
throwing i'm speculating all of my
employees are remote
i wouldn't know all right so i don't
want to know who really wants to go to
town let's
talk about tom cruise let's talk about
tom cruise so tom cruise
who is famous for you know not doing a
lot of interviews but when he does
interviews tom cruise has a tendency of
you know not uh holding back you know
whether it was the oprah winfrey one
kyle was talking about when he was
jumping i'm saying i love her
i'm in love i love her on the couch all
this stuff you know acting like a kid
and then he needs to be on a couch he's
kind of
wait anyways yeah vertically that's
interesting
exactly by the way if you ever said that
to his face he'd be very pissed off
please publicly i'm sorry right we
tracked that statement
in high heels i'm taller than you have
you have you ever seen him with matt
lauer the interview where they're
debating
ritalin and brook shields and all that
stuff you ever seen that or not let me
tell you
there's a part of him there's a part of
tom i like a lot
he's fiery dude no it's not the fiery
dude you know when he says
do you know what ritalin does do you
know what these drugs do yeah have you
actually looked at what these drugs do
unity says matt you need to do your
research no you gotta go cause you're
the journalist
so there's certain things he takes that
i like what he says
but he had a meltdown a couple days ago
and it was recorded and here's what it
sounded like and i think kai
has the recording let's see if he has
the right one we need a visual here for
heaven's sake no they don't have a
visual it's just a record one of the
employees apparently recorded him
losing his mind so let's get a picture
of a modern day tom cruise okay
let's get some visual to it put one we
can use so they don't come back saying
you use the wrong one
pull up the story because he's out there
okay let's hear this
all right here we go yeah you got the
audio
audio making movies right now because of
us because they believe in us
what we're i'm on the phone with every
studio at night insurance companies
producers and they're looking at us
and using us to make their movies we are
creating thousands of jobs
i don't ever want to see it again ever
and if you don't do it you're fired and
i see you do it again you're
gone and anyone on this crew does it
that's it and you too and you too
and you don't you ever do it again
that's it no apologies
you can tell it to the people that are
losing their own
because our industry is shut down it's
not going to put food on their table
or pay for their college education
that's what i sleep with every night
so i'm sorry i'm beyond your apologies i
have told you and now i want it and if
you don't do it you're out
we are not shutting this movie down
he's he's not messing around
is it understood if i see it again
you're
going and sure you so you're gonna cost
him his job
and i see it on the set you're going and
you're going
that's it am i clear do you
understand what i want you understand
the responsibility that you have
because i will deal with your reason
it's like the scene from uh tropic
thunder i will
you know what scene i'm talking about
tropic thunder tom shoulder when he
plays the uh
when he plays the super agent um patrick
do you think he's requiring the vaccine
so so so when you hear this how do you
prom how do you process it when you hear
this what do you think what was the
infraction so apparently
one of they were a little too close when
they were the editors they were a little
too close it was less than six feet and
he lost it
i gotta agree with tom on this one okay
maybe not in the manner in which he
completely had a freaking meltdown but
understand what he said
i'm the one that this falls on yeah i
gotta deal with the insurance companies
i'm creating thousands of jobs me me me
me but the reality is if he wasn't so
over the top he actually has a point
here all these people are working
we should have said i'm creating these
jobs hey guys just please stop
six like he should sound like that if he
didn't have that meltdown we would not
be talking about him but this is
this is very tom cruise issue look look
he does have truth to what he's doing
the movie industry
has suffered great i mean if there's
okay yes
here's a shout out to gavin newsom
here's a first and last
he wants it go for it go for it he is
looking forward to this one he has
employee of the year he has
deemed a studios in la to be essential
and allowed them to stay open
congratulations
okay how's that how's that food at
french laundry by the way
they just got a uh 3.5 million dollars
uh
ppp loan i think they just got it and a
big big loan not not a restaurant
no they just got um his business got 350
his vineyard and i think french laundry
got a massive check as well
what if french laundry just get a check
on go to french laundry pp
uh uh uh 2.4 million dollars one day the
restaurant
17 times more than the average
restaurant in the bay area they got 2.4
million dollars
french laundry is what they got so gavin
knew some uh
there are better places to eat so in the
wine valley so here's a question for you
by the way just so you know
five of his staffers quit this morning
tom cruise award just came out an hour
ago five of his staffers quit this
morning
right before we went live a fabulous
staffer's quote from uh
the the what do you call it the set
but there's a couple ways i process this
number one way i process this
is this guy's putting his own money on
the line
he's paid all the whatever things he has
to do to make it right he spent 500 000
of his own money to make this he's also
the producer yeah he is mission
impossible so he's putting his own money
on the line
so there's a couple ways you probably
some are saying oh some are speculating
saying this was intentional
he said this because he wants to be seen
and heard responsible
you know some are saying he did this
intentional the recording to leak
because
you know he's trying to use it to
promote uh the movie that's coming out i
don't know about that i don't know
what i will tell you is there's one
thing about tom cruise
the guy loves what he does for a living
and the guy
loves working you're hearing a guy
that is sick of not being able to do his
art and his craft that he loves
i'm a just so you know scientology i
interviewed one time a guy named mark
headley once i interviewed that guy i
got
emails from the headquarters of
scientology okay i got blocked by many
scientologists after that i did
i just did the interview and if you
watch the interview you would see me
challenging mark headley on what
scientology church did to him so it's
not an interview of
mark's like now i'm successful i'm a
millionaire i'm this i'm that i'm like
where did you learn that work ethic from
he says
yeah i guess i know where you're going
with this i'll probably learn how to
work out from being part of the church
of scientology
i said so where you work says anywhere
i've worked people have said i've never
met somebody that works as hard anyways
the moment i touch scientology block
from a bunch of different people that
are scientologists okay
and i got messages you set that aside
with tom cruise this guy's a stutter and
a half
he jumps out of airplanes guy's a
frickin i mean he has his own stunts
he's a stud he's not a media you know
he's not coming out saying hey look at
me i don't even know if he's got an
instagram account i don't think he's on
twitter
i don't think he cares if you know what
he wears
what he does he doesn't care to show to
the show he still never won an oscar
one of the best actors of all time who
have never won an oscar
this guy's done he had me you know you
know you had me at hello he did jerry
maguire which he crushed it
he did your top gun risky business
forget about those movies he did a few
good men
he did the rain man and when he did rain
man dustin hoffman won
so many of the people that did movies
with him want but this guy's never want
something he's he's going to be like
he's getting
kidding me he's going to get a lifetime
achievement that's pathetic the guy
is a brilliant guy 60 yet how old is he
gotta be guessing he's late 50s yeah but
you know what you're going for
you're also guessing that he's more in
shape than anybody else in here in his
late 50s 58
okay here's he looks great he looks
great you know stressed out though
no doubt about it he's stressed out but
that's a stressed out of a person to me
but what was he saying to go back to
your life possible
i'm on the phone with insurance
companies at night so you're saying ceos
should not require vaccines and yet
they're talking to their insurance
companies about bringing their
workers back into the office yeah but he
lost five staffers so meaning there's a
risk for whatever position you take he's
the point i'm trying to make use
everybody he's gonna replace them in
five minutes but
i know he's gonna replace him in five
minutes it's the annoying phase of
trying to replace somebody that's doing
the job that you got to go and say put
it out there find somebody
wait a week qualifying background check
two-week notice i guess
it's not easy i hear you it's time it's
the three weeks that you don't want to
take with the set people being there
right so but here's here's where i'm
going with this part here's where i'm
going with this part
look who ended up seeing like the dick
here the here who
tom cruise is the he's the ceo
the ceo of the project
ended up being the because he's
trying to do what's responsible
and still the world is saying what a
freaking you know
what a freaking this guy is and
he doesn't care about this thing doesn't
care about that
you don't think he has pressure that no
one knows about you think he's you think
the pressure he has is money pressure
do you think he wakes up in the morning
so i got to pay my bills you think it's
that pressure oh i think it's the
pressure of
let me do my work and my art and go back
to being one of the guys please be
responsible for them
people are relying on us to send their
kids to college people are relying on us
to put food on the table
he was i mean i will defend a lot of
what he was saying because he was saying
the industry is using this filming
as a benchmark to see measure the
efficacy of
opening up filmmaking again in a bigger
way
where we are representative of something
bigger
than just this movie he said that he
spoke for
employees sounded like an ambassador he
sounded like a pissed off ambassador
saying we're going to set the tone for
everybody
really creative usage of the fbi i mean
he can use it in many different ways
grammatically speaking
i tell you one thing if you ever
listened to how we spoke in the military
you know you would like you would think
we had an obsession with the f-bomb it
was every other word was so
you know that's why they say cussing
like a sailor yeah you know you know
sports military i'm sure you're on the
set you're ticked off i mean you guys in
christian do you have some christian bay
loser
you ever seen christian buildings so you
think about the people that have lost it
chris berman lost it once
does anybody here know what after
they're doing does anybody know their
job german
you've never seen chris berman lose i
would show it if youtube wouldn't censor
but you don't know
riley bill o'reilly's do it live let's
do it live
oh god you've never seen glenn beck
losing he's victorious okay
yes you're right karen you we should do
this
you all you rich people shut up
you've never seen that oh my god did you
see
that one out of them you guys are
already like cutting
did you the rick santelli thing
cnbc oh yeah yeah i saw rick that was
he says there has to be a better way
than this there has to be
and then the last guesses so how's that
working out for you
how's that working out for you rick but
i you know what i respect him for being
able to push the envelope with his own
co-workers
this all reminds me of this every single
meltdown speaking of tom cruise
tell us i want the truth yeah i want the
truth and he doesn't have enough
and he doesn't
dude i've been looking for that for 42
years i want the truth as well so
it's been a lifelong mission lifelong
mission okay so
is that is that enough to get tom cruise
out of our system is that the time
yeah i'm happy to just finish it up
someone under the bus here i have to kai
i gotta throw mario under the bus
i love martin you know watch i think
it's mario that's shutting down the
today's area
watch he's going to pull it he's going
to pull the tijuana lines mario was here
early this morning
he's about to walk in he's about to walk
in with a ccp shirt on and
you know we have our pitch stories
danielle was on i was on zoom yesterday
you walked out of the meeting i'm left
with eric and kai
and mario all right guys let's wrap up
what stories want to do i go hey i think
we should cover this tom cruise story
it's pretty big
mara's like no i don't think that i
think maybe that's a different something
i go later
you know like i think it's a pretty big
story i think people are going to be
interested in it tom cruise i don't know
we're going back and forth
you you cannot have that you can't you
cannot have a female in the room
who pauses the volleyball scene in top
gun and say tom cruise and not talk
about it
i'm sorry you just you gotta you gotta
go there okay
is he a top ten best looking male actor
of all time
would you put him in as a top ten i'll
let daniel he looks like he's in your
double
yes yes don't say no danielle not to my
tommy boy
well is it the top ten let me put it
this way the fact that he's a badass
makes him more attractive than he
actually is
i so agree with you i so agree with you
yeah i think he's about us look i i give
him a pass on this one
because i think of him as a ceo
frustrated annoyed trying to do the
responsibility
because he was speaking for the
employees who want to work in this
country i i respect he's a capitalist
good for him
so no negative from me about tom's here
wrap this story up
tom cruise on mario you don't want to do
the tom cruise story it we won't do
it don't talk
about that we'll do this hello sorry
danielle family-friendly show here
yes oh this is a video her four kids
watch this show what are you doing every
single time you do this man now
i'm i'm giving you and remember her kids
speak mandarin
you have to understand be very careful
commander and i would have said all
right so let's talk about facebook
against apple facebook accuses apple of
anti-competitive behavior over privacy
by the way that's very interesting if
you when you get into it facebook uh
talks about one's aftershock irony here
firing another shot in a month-long
standoff between the two tech giants
over apple's plan privacy changes on ios
14 apple is behaving
anti-competitively by using their
control of the app store to benefit
their bottom line at the expense of
creators and small businesses
full stop facebook vice president for
ads and business products
dan levy told reporters the world's
biggest social media company
ran full-page ads and major newspapers
criticizing apple's plan
which will limit apps ability to gather
data from other phones
that will be used for targeting
advertising apple said in june that such
activity will require a pop-up
notification asking ios users for
permission to track your
you across apps and websites owned by
other companies which digital
advertising firms expect most
will decline facebook and apple have
also tangled over commission fees the
iphone maker charges apps
listed on ios devices with facebook
again aligning itself with small
developers most
affected by this policy thoughts well we
we we all saw what happened with apple
and epic games and fortnite
and everything with that and that was
something we covered on the top on the
podcast yeah
many times but something that a theme of
this podcast that we've had this entire
time is competition
and holding other states or countries
accountable
to see apple and facebook go at it
i freaking love it two legitimate
monopolies right now yeah exactly
all right so we we said that you know
apple is on the verge of what forty
six percent forty six percent six
percent of smartphones
face us facebook is currently dealing
with anti-trust lawsuits are there i
mean
biden's trying to get him to break apart
with whatsapp and instagram
i you know amazon versus walmart
who's winning that one for me i i'm not
trying to get two in the tech
they're taking out full-page ads like to
see apple
and facebook go at it i can appreciate
that the question is
who's more powerful who's an actually
more powerful company apple
or facebook again you know
my mom hat is on right now and i think
privacy is a big issue
so you're you're going with you're
defending apple i think i think you
should be
as private as you want to be yeah and i
think you should know
if somebody's infringing upon your
privacy i don't think that that should
be something that you have to
find out by watching the social dilemma
you're like whoa
no no no i think privacy is a bigger
issue than what we
appreciate and i think people like the
the
the kid in vermont who's been who's been
holed up for seven
months somebody's following him
somebody's
tracking everything and and they're
preying upon his weaknesses
yep they are they're infringing upon his
privacy i see what you're saying so
they're bringing up the videos that he
will you know take him to the rabbit
hole of other videos yeah
they're praying so i i think privacy uh
i i don't think that's something that
america has explored deeply enough so
i'm curious if you're watching this
right now who
who are you defending are you with
danielle on apple if you are smash the
thumbs up button
if you're saying no i think facebook
should be allowed to target whoever they
want to target with their ads because if
they don't they're going to be
hitting some revenue issues put thumbs
down but thumbs up for apple thumbs down
to defend facebook i'm curious to know
what you guys will say about it
adam what are your thoughts on on this
topic
i'd just love to see these two companies
going at it i don't know if there's any
clear-cut
that's your oh come on these are moral
issues you're talking about put so much
time into creating opinions about these
issues adam like seriously
this is this is something where i just
think i i love that these two companies
are holding each other accountable i
like it we're going to have to get you
some children
i would like some daniel okay i think
you're going to make an
awesome i'm still thinking about tom
cruise bro i think you're gonna make it
awesome well he's not gonna help you
make children yeah no
no that's good he is in your top ten
though no question he's in your top ten
that's impressive he's number one though
who's number one dicaprio's probably
gonna leave yeah
he's probably a top three guy freaking
guy you know he's
kissed only one girl in his life but
okay so let's go back to this facebook
clooney okay period cool there you go
cool yeah george cronin i think there's
something about robert downey jr with
you know it's very very cool and
different
denzel's a freaking badass guy that's
just like a dance mask
yeah i don't know about you guys so how
do we go
i talk facebook apple you're going to
sexy man like what is up with adam today
you're all over the place like you've
been salivating you've text
i got six emails this morning waking up
saying adam wants you to cover tom
cruise
it's the hobbies so we covered it for
you let's get that out of yourself he
already said he's celebrating christmas
kwanzaa
and hanukkah so he's like the happiest
guy in the room yeah
maybe we should take a look at his
search history and we'd understand that
we would if we
did facebook well no it would be uh
what's the other one it would be uh
just as facebook what is the other one
that we were talking about last time the
search history what's that one company
where you get five bucks for pizza or
whatever what is it
this is only fans only fans your website
that's where you go live okay
the girl that i was talking to in miami
it turns out she was an only fan account
and now
maybe she was hoping for you to be her
only fan maybe that's what it was
i don't know that's a play i don't know
let's go back
baby department by the now she's got the
right equipment yes
i agree just fyi are you familiar with
this only fan situation
you don't even know about it
please tell me because my one of my
children might be anyways
continue you
if you don't say they're definitely
going to go to it aoc has come out and
said now officially they don't
understand that
sex work is work yeah she tweeted that
yesterday she said sex work is worse
that's what was working pardon me so
basically she tweeted yesterday saying
sex work is you're working you know how
sex workers in many
uh ways are recruited you know how bad
she got trashed on twitter when she said
that
she got crushed on twitter yesterday but
she got a retweet from adam which was uh
well we've been talking oh for the love
of god
you're about to get i'm about to hit the
eject button mr tom cruise
i'm not liking her tweets i'm just and
and actually
you know you've seen the shirts that
attacks the wrists she has taxed the
rich do you heard the shirt that i made
something i know rhymes with rich yes
tax the
so that's why the young lady so facebook
apple let's wrap this up with facebook
apple before we go to the next topic
yeah
what's going on this is actually a big
deal let me explain to you why let me
explain to you why
so small business so two arguments on
both sides
arguments on both sides okay who has the
bigger monopoly
if you ask it would you say facebook
yeah
that was the good conversation who has
the bigger monopoly facebook or apple
who has more power
you say facebook what do you say i don't
know i mean with the whole 46 percent of
smartphones
i'm here okay okay so the monopoly is
but they're not talking about breaking
up after we are talking about breaking
up facebook
yeah let's go ahead to to go to facebook
you have to pick up
the apple iphone to go to facebook you
got to pick up the apple
ipad to go to facebook you got to pick
up your
apple mac pro you know whatever you want
to call it
you have to go all roads lead to
apple okay so the 46
buddy that's a lot of roads but you're
talking 54
dude you're forgetting apps music
beats you're forgetting i watch you
forget apple watch you're forgetting
you're forgetting so many different
things that these guys are just
dominating the market with okay plus if
you have if you if you send someone a
text and it comes up green
they make fun of you we we forced eric
oh yeah gosh that scares me i
interviewed the guy with 30 million
subscribers who's the number one tech
guy on youtube that you know talks about
all these different things phones that's
coming out
actually i can't wait to for the viewers
to see it it was a great conversation
he's a genius but going back to this
okay
apple is pushing their weight around man
that's a scary thought
it's a scary scary thought and facebook
has to be very careful because facebook
needs apple and if apple wants to make
facebook's life a living hell they could
easily do it
so facebook has to be very very careful
because all roads don't lead to facebook
all roads lead to apple that leads to
facebook i have to go to appletown to
find facebook i don't go to facebook
town to find apple
to that part apple has that facebook has
to keep in mind the other part
where facebook is right what facebook is
saying is right let me get facebook
aside okay
a small business owner doesn't have a
lot of money to advertise
small business owners not advertising a
million dollars a month a small business
owner is advertising a thousand a week
two thousand a week five thousand a week
for them to not be able to target the
audience to their
city you know location streets
demographic all that dude you're so now
i have to spend four times the amount of
money to find the niche market that i
want to find because now i can't get
targeted at so the advertiser stops if
the small business owner stops
advertising to the targeted market that
they have
that that small business owner now takes
a hit so i understand
why facebook is siding with the small
business owner but
they also have to realize that king kong
in this situation
is apple you have to watch how you talk
to apple
it's that simple it's called it's called
free enterprise and competition bro
you're going to push them around you you
have to be very very
respectful when you're dealing with
apple it's that simple and facebook may
sound like they're
a caring company but this also has to do
true they're
you're right absolutely sorry but what
i'm saying is i like the angle they took
with their focus
on the small creator small business
owners i mean my gosh right now in
america
sure exactly i mean that's that's good
pr i get it but no you're right and in
terms of who who wears the pants you're
absolutely right if they were scared
like you're saying they have to they
need to be careful why are they taking
out full full-page ads in newspapers
criticizing them isn't that the exact
opposite isn't that putting their
out there and saying
nah buddy we're going to come at you and
we're going to put you in all the major
publications
and we don't care what you have to say
because we're going to put it out there
what's what's their thought process
there if they were
um so so by the way just so you know
most of the audience uh uh
voted for apple over facebook is what
the audience said here so yeah did you
have did you have to turn your mic once
i can't hear you
no uh my only question there was because
apple obviously has been taking a
big like their big marketing effort in
privacy
yeah where they're marketing that we're
big on privacy so then
limiting the consumer and essentially
protecting the person from
somebody overstepping their bounds my
question for you would then be
um regardless of is facebook or apple
the bigger monopoly
who is overstepping their bounds more
facebook or apple
because you know the uh the whole when
people say they have their phone there
they talk about cat food and then
suddenly they're seeing cat food
commercials like even though
facebook's not even remotely open or
active on the app
it might be lingering on the back well
that part is a different story the whole
thing with
instagram got caught watching you with
their camera and then they said oh we're
so sorry
i have a problem with that that's a
different story that's the kind of that
is
what at least kind of how that's
slippery that's what they're trying to
limit of basically saying that you have
to enable it
i don't i think there's other way i
think look i think there's a happy
medium
targeting if i'm targeting you based on
what some of the targeting i think the
small business owner only helps them out
no yeah but the targeting of camera
listen that's a that's criminal offense
that's the stuff that should go to court
you're recording what i'm doing what are
you talking about here exactly no that
that's that's a crime
situation by the way you know you know
what happens if you work at a
a retail store and you know the peep
stuff they would put camera some
employees got cut you know what happens
that's a that's a federal offense you're
going to jail when you're putting the
camera in the
changing room oh yeah so that's pretty
much what they're doing they're putting
the camera in the changing room except
it's my bedroom
not okay with that with interesting
instagram with instagram
with that last time i remember we had a
conversation with my buddy joe and he
said ask you oh if you go to norway
you're going to go to the
what was the word it's like you're gonna
go to the slope so with some weird word
you're like oh yeah of course
in the gym i don't recall anything okay
you don't remember what he asked and
it's something in norway
you're right adam and then he's like uh
dude something popped up the other day
on the uh
oh that's let's talk about this let's
talk about trump mar-a-lago real quick
last story we've got 12 minutes before
we wrap up
president donald trump's neighbors
mar-a-lago are taking legal action to
try to convince them to leave
trump's florida neighbors are not happy
with them wanting to be their permanent
resident according to washington post
neighbors reportedly wrote a letter to
palm beach authorities and the u.s
secret service saying trump had no legal
rights to live there full time citing
legal precedent over
from an agreement that trump signed in
1993 when he sought to turn
what he had been a residence into a
private club under the terms of the
agreement no guess is permitted to stay
in the club for more than three
non-consecutive day periods during one
one year according to the post the
letter says palm beach authorities
should promptly notify trump he is not
allowed to live in mar-a-lago to avoid
an embarrassing situation
in which a former president had to be
evicted
that's it you like the story
daniel likes this story a lot
opinions adam thoughts i'm trying to get
kai this thing over here
okay about what did you say epstein oh
he i like him he likes young girls
yeah sorry what do you say about what
they're doing okay do you have an
opinion on this you look like you want
to say something yeah i just sent kai
something yes i do have an opinion go
ahead guys
check your text though though tell me if
you know that signed in contract then i
don't think there's too much he can do
i mean obviously he'll probably try to
fight it but
if it's signed it's signed
here's where i think trump should live i
think trump should live
in the state where he received
the highest percentage of the votes
that's where i think he should move no
more mar-a-lago i'm sorry you need to go
to your base so he needs to go to either
wyoming alabama west virginia
that's his people that's where he needs
to go if he loves those people he loves
him so much that's where i think he
should live
no more with mar-a-lago i think and i'm
not even saying that disrespectfully i
mean that
you love these people go live stop
stop it hillary clinton she won the most
votes in new york she moved to new york
yeah
obama yeah i registered to vote so that
i could vote against your guys
trump should go live in west virginia
that's where i think you should go no
more mar-a-lago for you
double down the double down when when i
when i was at
breakers a couple months ago i asked a
lot of people so how do you guys feel
about you know trump being here how do
you feel about trump being here i don't
feel about trump being here
it was mixed feelings a lot of people
said some of them
who were on the higher ups they said
look we kind of don't mind him because
he
increased the value here a lot of people
want a movie i want to look at trump's
house that's on the market right now for
135 million
went through the realtor was a very good
friend with trump for the last 32 years
while i'm speaking to him
uh steve wynn called you know we're
having a conversation all this stuff so
we look at the
beautiful home 70 million dollars of art
in there to be able to
get the audience to be more excited
about wanting to make a bid on this 135
million
home so there are those that say he did
very good for
the city okay to bring mar-a-lago into
what he did
there's those that say when he's here
roadsuck transportation i can't get
through there's a three-hour wait
because when he wants to go to the beach
the secret service
goes and i'm so sick of it because i
can't take my route if i want to get
home i don't make it on time
there's only one way for me to make it
home it takes me two hours to get home
so there is because if you've been to
palm beach and know how the city is
you literally only can go there from a
couple different places it's not like
they're so
it's like trying to get off trying to
get off the freeway in new jersey
understand what they're saying
i actually understand what they're
saying don't forget jared kushner and
uh ivanka bought a house on one of those
islands down there so
uh there's a part of it that i
understand for how the community is
being affected by it
the other part of it is the guys guys
he's going to go want to live wherever
he wants to live if we just say he can't
live in a place
you know he's gonna find a way to revoke
this and figure out a way to live
anywhere he wants to live the guy has
enough money to go buy a house anywhere
uh but he likes palm beach he likes
mar-a-lago who knows what's gonna happen
with what he's gonna do
um i hope when it's whatever i say right
now i hope
uh whatever takes place next you know as
biden
you know you got the uh electoral
college came out you know
uh december 14th that they came out oh
it's official it's this it's that okay
came out and putin called and all these
guys are calling okay so we're going in
this direction
i hope i hope i hope
that both the media like the other day
jake tapper came out and said what
thinks trump's done good
okay he actually said a couple things
that trump has done good on his
administration
sort of sarcastically but he did give
him credit in the beginning he did give
him a little bit of credit
i hope there's some of that going on
because
you know that could also calm him down
for him to go away and just kind of do
his own thing okay
i hope the media also doesn't constantly
poke the bear
over and over and over again which i
don't think that's gonna i don't think
that's gonna happen
number two i don't think he's gonna call
him number two let me give the number
two i hope
he does a little bit in the transition i
don't think he's going to because he and
his base
fully believe there was fraud which
there's a lot of proof of it you can see
a lot of proof of it
but in court it didn't hold weight and
to be able to have
your proof go to the next level you got
to be able to get the justices to side
with you you got to be able to get some
of these governors so i want to turn
things around you got to be able to get
some of these
local justices and unfortunately it's
battle after battle after battle he
keeps
you so we keep saying proof and there's
a lot of people out there that believe
that there was fraud cool i respect your
opinion
but at what point when every single
court says no
no there wasn't at what point was every
single
state uh governor uh
secretary of state remember how many
people at what point did they say all
right like
you lost how many liberal fans of
hillary clinton who will love hillary
clinton can you convince that she lost
the election to trump
how many so there's actually a number on
that 30 percent of people
30 of democrats were thinking that there
was illegitimate
30 percent okay there you go 75 of
republicans
so more than double that's normal though
that's not a big number that's what do
you mean
30 of democrats basically said no it's
illegitimate we don't believe that
trump's the president
seventy-five percent of republicans now
that's not that's it
said what that that is illegitimate yeah
i saw that i saw okay so that's not even
close that's what i'm saying
but i i s that that just means there are
more true believers of trump than they
were true believers of hillary which
makes sense to me because it's fine
trump is a bigger personality
but at one point but at what point do
you say all right like
the supreme court every single court
every four year somebody loses and
whoever loses is emotional give it time
okay you're saying a lot of is an
emotion not logic uh yeah
i think everything right now quite
frankly if i was if i was the die-hard
republican fan right
if i'm the die-hard trump guy you know
what my number one focus is if i'm a
die-hard trump
trump fan georgia that's my number one
focus if i'm a die-hard principles of
the right
your number one priority ought to be
true he shouldn't have called
into question the integrity of kemp
no the integrity of elections yeah
because you're
because you're going to have a harder
time getting out the vote in georgia
because of this yeah in my opinion the
final thought here
he was calling it a rigged election in
2016. he somehow won
right now it's another rigged election
in 2020 he somehow see what's gonna
happen i hope so they don't they don't
bother him with him wanting to live in
mar-a-lago if he wants to live in a
place like this i hope they
or in west virginia or you know west
virginia's got a better song than palm
beach i don't know
a song in palm beach that goes as good
as the one from west virginia
having said that gang the folk those of
you guys that stuck around with us
even after the uh outage on youtube or
whatever that was we appreciate you
uh for the love if you guys enjoyed the
dialogue today with danielle and adam
and myself and kai
and kyle and sam and eric
smash that subscribe button so we can
get this thing to a hundred thousand so
we can start potentially doing this
three times a week take care everybody
bye bye bye bye
you